let me ask a
a ridiculous tangent of a question
louise you wrote a paper
on uh on game of thrones battle of
winterfell just
as a side i'm sorry i noticed i'm sure
you've done a lot of ridiculous stuff
like this i just noticed that particular
one
by ridiculous i mean ridiculously
awesome can you describe
the the approach in this work which i
believe is a legitimate publication
so going back to the original like uh
when we were talking about the backstory
of of papers and the importance of that
so this is actually
you know there was a uh when the last
season of the the show was
airing uh this was a during a company
lunch we there was in in the last season
there's the
there's a really big battle against the
the
forces of evil and the you know the
forces of good and this is called the
battle of winterfell
and um in this battle there are like
these two armies
and there's a very particular thing that
they have to take into account
is that in the army of dead like if
someone dies in the army of the living
like that person is gonna you know be a
reborn as
a soldier in the army of the dead yes
and so that was a
an important thing to take into account
yeah and the initial conditions as you
specify it's about a hundred thousand on
each side
exactly so i was able i was able to like
based on some images
like on previous episodes to figure out
what was the size of the armies and so
what i want what we wanted to do
what we were theorizing was like how
many soldiers
does like a a soldier on the army of the
living has to kill
in order for them to be able to just to
destroy the army of the dead
without like uh losing because every
time uh uh one of the good soldiers dies
gonna turn into like the other side and
so it's
so i we we were theorizing that and and
i wrote a couple of
uh differential equations and i was able
to figure out that based on the
the size of the armies i think i think
was the ratio had to be like 1.7
so it had to kill like 1.7 um soldiers
like the army of the dead in order for
them to win the battle
well yeah that's that's science it is
it's
it's most powerful and this is also
somehow a pitch
for uh like a hiring pitch in a sense
like this is the kind of
important science you do at least
exactly well it turned out to be you
know as
is for people that have watched these
shows is like they know that every time
you
try to predict something that is gonna
happen it's gonna you're gonna fail
miserably
and that's what happened so it was not
not at all important
for the show but yeah we ended up like
putting that out and there was a lot of
people that shared that
i think with some like elements of the
ca of the show the cast of the show
that actually retweeted that and shared
that that was fun
you